bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est science public votre
rendez-vous de débat de reportage et
d'analyse comme tous les soirs sur
Public Sénat grâce à nos experts vous le
savez on cherche à donner du sens à
l'actualité avec comme chaque soir deux
grands thèmes et d'abord chaque geste
compte c'est le slogan du plan de
sobriété énergétique dévoilé par
Elisabeth borne et une dizaine de
ministres cet après-midi le maître mot
c'est l'incitation pour les ménages
l'administration va te montrer l'exemple
et puis les entreprises et les
collectivités locales sont également
incitées à baisser les températures on
va décortiquer ce plan dans un instant
et puis pour notre second débat ce
chiffre 6 millions de Français n'ont pas
de médecins traitant parmi eux 10%
souffrent d'une affection de longue
durée comment mettre fin au désert
médico faut-il obliger les médecins à
s'installer dans ses campagnes aux
abandonnés réponses dans trois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord donc ce plan de
sobriété annoncé par la Premier ministre
première ministre objectif faire baisser
de 10% notre de consommation d'énergie
par rapport à 2019 Mathias Arès entre
baisse du chauffage et incitation au
télétravail s'est avant tout à
l'exemplarité qu'appelle le gouvernement
ce jeudi dans son plan de sobriété cette
mobilisation générale que nous lançons
et où les acteurs les plus gros les plus
grandes entreprises les plus grandes
collectivités locales les
administrations montrent l'exemple il
serait inacceptable de demander aux
Français de faire des efforts et que ces
grandes institutions ne fassent pas des
efforts face à des entrepreneurs
Emmanuel Macron a également rappelé que
pour leur ces mesures ne sont pas
coercitives à condition que chacun y
mette du sien la Nation toute entière
arrive à tenir cet objectif qui est
purement volontariste faut pas décrire
de loi de choses compliquées si on se
mobilise tous pour le tenir
dans les pires scénarios on passe
l'hiver l'objectif est clair baisser de
10% notre consommation par rapport à
2019 du côté des oppositions le LR Bruno
Retailleau regrette la méthode qui
faille changer de culture je suis
d'accord mais une fois de plus le
gouvernement est dans la communication
il est aussi dans l'infantilisation une
forme de pédagogie qui dit aux Français
à écouter soyez capable de mieux faire
un petit peu comme un maître d'école
vis-à-vis de ses élèves en cas d'échec
le gouvernement se réserve la
possibilité de prendre des mesures
contraignantes allant jusqu'à des
coupures ciblées d'électricité
centrales à gaz je vous présente mes
invités tout de suite Sandra ouabillon
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes directrice
générale du centre de recherche pour
l'étude et l'observation des conditions
de vie le credoch et vous êtes docteur
en sociologie Béatrice bonsoir bienvenue
géographe directrice de la revue
Hérodote j'accue également Erwan Benezet
bonsoir bon bienvenue c'est une journée
socialiste économique du Parisien ou
publier d'ailleurs vous étiez venus nous
parler de nucléaire il y a quelques
semaines nucléaires une catastrophe
française audition
Fayard et j'accue également Laetitia cru
pas éditoris politique bonsoir Laetitia
je vous propose on a on a terminé le
sujet de Mathias avec l'image
d'Elizabeth borne qui arrivait au
pupitre tient un extrait de sa
déclaration c'était il y a il y a
quelques minutes en cette fin
d'après-midi elle rappelle l'ambition de
ce plan de sobriété
certains voudraient réduire la sobriété
à quelques symboles voire voir la tourne
en dérision
aujourd'hui pourtant la sobriété n'a
jamais été une question aussi sérieuse
c'est une des clés de notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement c'est un gage pour
notre souveraineté c'est une opportunité
pour notre pouvoir d'achat c'est un
fondement pour la transition écologique
la sobriété est là pour s'installer
c'est une opportunité pour nous comme
pour notre société
la sobriété est là pour s'installer on
viendra évidemment sur sur cette phrase
mais peut-être une appréciation générale
sur sur ce plan pour commencer Sandra
webian je l'ai dit en titre le
gouvernement choisi l'incitation il a
raison
alors il a raison dans le sens où
aujourd'hui les ménages sont déjà dans
des situations assez contraintes
l'augmentation des prix de l'inflation
des prix de l'énergie pèsent beaucoup
sur leur budget il y a déjà eu des
budgets voilà en très forte augmentation
donc c'est vrai que
il y a peu de marge de manœuvre donc à
court terme effectivement on est dans
l'incitation après il y a beaucoup
d'autres leviers qui peuvent faire
bouger les ménages et notamment les
plans d'investissement de long terme
donc sur les transports les
infrastructures parce qu'en fait on a
beau dire aux gens fait ci fête ça si à
côté de chez eux il y a pas un transport
en commun qui est facilement accessible
en fait ils vont pas changer leur mode
de déplacement de la même manière il y a
aussi des questions d'information donc
là il y a beaucoup de choses qui sont
qui sont faites au niveau de
l'information parce que d'une certaine
manière on dit aussi bah voilà les
gestes qui comptent ça c'est quelque
chose d'assez positif aussi pour faire
bouger les comportements et puis après
il y a la question de l'équité et là
aussi je pense qu'on peut voir un signal
positif puisque
ont été mis en l'action notamment des
collectifs des administrations et des
entreprises or c'est souvent un reproche
qui est fait par les ménages dire bah
oui mais nous on ne demande pas aux
autres donc toutes ces dimensions sont
quand même des dimensions qui vont on va
dire dans le bon sens pour encourager
les ménages à bouger mais voilà les
ménages ont beaucoup de contraintes et
donc c'est pas simplement des
incitations qui peuvent les faire
changer de comportement
si je vous entends Béatrice Gibelin
qu'est-ce que vous retenez vous de ce
plan sur
la citation comme vous l'avez dit
c'est-à-dire pas de contrainte mais je
pense que tout le monde au moins au
niveau politique se souvient que avoir
imposé 80 km/h plutôt 90 sur les routes
nationales savaient quand même déclenché
c'est quand même ça qui était à
l'origine du mouvement des gilets jaunes
d'abord après ça a été d'autres facteurs
mais le premier c'était celui-là donc
bien sûr
si vous avez la France cet été ça dépend
qu'on est très prudent si vous voulez
comme il y a déjà beaucoup de
contraintes imposées par un jean
pincendie km/h sur l'autoroute là vous
risquez de mettre le feu aux poudres on
pourrait dire maintenant avec du prime
carburant élevé logiquement ils vont
baisser leur vitesse mais comme le prix
du carburant s'amment de sa baisse et
que quand total rajoute 20 centimes du
coup tout le monde se précipite et on se
retrouve avec des stations services à
sec enfin c'est c'est un peu brouillon
tout ça et mais je crois aussi que l'été
qu'on vient de passer avec la sécheresse
les gens ont pris vraiment conscience
que c'était pas une sécheresse comme ça
mais qu'on était vraiment dans un
processus qui est un processus de
réchauffement climatique donc je pense
que les esprits sont mieux préparés non
à faire les efforts dans la durée c'est
ce qu'a dit Elisabeth borne c'est pas
seulement parce à la guerre en Ukraine
et qu'on doit passer l'hiver c'est qu'on
est parti pour un changement de
comportement d'économie d'énergie qui
devient absolument nécessaire puis
dernier point le prix est tellement
élevé que c'est très dissuatif et que
quand on voit la note d'électricité
qu'on a bah on essaye d'éteindre la
lumière ou effectivement prendre une
douche moins longue quand il y a un
chauffage collectif dans un immeuble on
l'allume peut-être pas aussi tôt que que
les années précédentes
Erwan Belize le Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France a pu dévoiler ce matin le plan en
avant-première il y a
cette idée de de prise de conscience
collective quand même dans dans la
stratégie générale de du gouvernement
vous le rappeliez en fait
malheureusement la météo a joué dans ce
sens avant comme une sorte de grand
propos liminaire à
ce qui était présenté aujourd'hui avec
le plan sobriété avec tous les épisodes
de sécheresse et et là en fait là où
sans doute le le gouvernement joue en
tout cas est très prudent c'est que la
contrainte elle existe déjà la vraie
grosse contrainte ça sera la contrainte
de des enjeux climatiques ça c'est la
sécheresse qu'on a vu c'est la manière
dont ça pèse donc le sur la ressource en
nous et on le voit ensuite que ça pèse
sur la production d'électricité que ça
pèse sur l'eau potable que ça pèse sur
l'agriculture bref ça va ça touche de
beaucoup de poste ça touche aussi le
tourisme et donc en fait ces contraintes
là sont déjà présentes très fortes
infusent malheureusement ou heureusement
dans l'esprit des gens on peut dire
heureusement même si à court terme c'est
c'est très dur pour malheureusement pour
beaucoup de secteurs mais sauf que cette
transition il faut il faut l'amener on
en est tous conscients et le
gouvernement se dit il y a un cadre
aujourd'hui il y a un contexte qui fait
que on n'a pas vraiment besoin de plus
contraindre que ça en tout cas sur les
ménages et en fait il reprend presque
une théorie économique que auquel
Emmanuel Macron est rattaché qui est
celle du ruissellement vous savez la
richesse qui va arriver de d'en haut et
puis qui va ruisseler jusqu'en bas là il
y a une forme de ruissellement et je
crois que certains membres du
gouvernement ont utilisé ce terme ou
effectivement l'exemple donné par les
administrations l'exemple donné par les
entreprises vont ruisseler et vont faire
que les ménages vont se dire ok bah nous
aussi on va s'y mettre alors justement
je vous ai promis on va décortiquer un
peu
mesures par mesure alors ce plan de
sobriété concernant les administrations
bâtiments chauffés à 18 degrés en cas de
grande tension énergétique pas d'eau
chaude dans les sanitaires sauf pour les
douches quand il y en a incitation en
télétravail et alors vous l'évoquez
baisse de la vitesse des véhicules de
service pour les véhicules de service ça
sera effectivement 110 pour autoroute
après qu'on commence ce sera contrôlé
c'est une vraie question pourquoi Sandra
va bien si on rentre vraiment dans le
détail pourquoi ce signal il est
important
dans l'acceptation de finalement de
mesures de restriction collective parce
que il y a souvent un sentiment d'une
d'un écart entre le mode de vie des
Français et les élites et Paris et
l'administration qui
serait toujours un petit peu à part par
rapport aux normes de sociétés par
rapport au contrainte donc le fait de
montrer que la puissance publique est
moteur et fait des efforts
à un impact positif en fait sur la sur
la population on l'a vu aussi pendant la
crise covid par exemple le fait que les
administrations se soient mobilisées ça
restaurer la confiance des citoyens
envers les institutions on en parle plus
mais pendant très longtemps on parlait
de la baisse de la confiance dans les
institutions avec cette période où
l'État reprend un peu sa place ou une
place en tout cas on voit que le lien se
se raffermit donc l'exemple arité c'est
aussi un moyen de restaurer la confiance
et ensuite
d'opérer des changements le comportement
allez-y Laetitia j'ai l'impression
d'être la seule pessimiste sur ce
plateau parce que moi j'entends tout ce
que dit le gouvernement c'est très voilà
son discours est très clair son message
est très clair mais il y a un mais
si on y arrive pas il y aura des
coupures d'électricité et vous risquez
de subir des coupures qui seront
contraignantes pour tout le monde il
faut être prudent là-dessus les ménages
il y a très très peu de chance pour
qu'il subisse des coupures électricité
en réalité les coupures seront des
coupures ciblées ce sont du DSA ciblés
ou des stages tournants pour les
coupures et avant les coupures il y aura
du rationnement c'est-à-dire on
demandera de baisser à un moment
certaines entreprises leurs production
en tout cas de décaler leurs production
et tout ça justement pour protéger les
ménages pour protéger les hôpitaux pour
protéger les activités essentielles et
donc ça va être ça va être aux
entreprises mais en fait avant ça même
il y a le signal prix qui est donné et
c'est sans doute ça qui pèse le plus sur
les entreprises elles-mêmes cet hiver
puisque les Français vont être quand
même protégés par le bouclier tarifaire
y compris en 2023 on le sait maintenant
plus 15% sur le gaz électricité mais
certaines entreprises donc ça veut dire
ça ira pas au-delà de 15% c'est ça ce
que vous exactement c'est-à-dire que on
va on va l'électricité qui avait été
déjà les prix qui était déjà gelés 4%
pour l'électricité 12,6% en octobre 2020
pour le gaz les deux vont augmenter de
15% au 1er janvier pour le gaz et au 1er
février pour l'électricité ça n'ira pas
au-delà on est protégé il y aura un coup
par contre pour les citoyens pour le
nous qui payons les impôts puisque ça
pèse à hauteur de 45 milliards brut sur
sur le budget de la France mais les
entreprises elles par ce signal prix
d'une électricité d'un gaz extrêmement
fort pour certaines d'entre elles ne
savent pas comment faire aujourd'hui
elles ne savent pas ce qu'elles vont
signer avec des fournisseurs pour
l'année prochaine juste pour ajouter un
élément il y a aussi aujourd'hui plus de
40% des ménages qui déjà nous disent
qu'ils ont réduit leur chauffage qu'ils
ont renoncé à des déplacements notamment
les déplacements de loisirs les
déplacements pour voir des proches donc
on a vraiment des augmentations tous ces
taux on a aussi une augmentation de la
proportion de Français qui dit qu'il y a
du mal à payer ses factures on est passé
de 10% à 18% l'espace d'un an donc de
toutes les manières en fait ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure c'est que les
marges de manœuvre individuelles sont
aussi limitées pour réduire vraiment
l'impact l'impact carbone et énergétique
c'est beaucoup des actions sur la
rénovation des logements et sur les
infrastructures de transport qui peuvent
vraiment faire bouger les ménages je
reste sur le chapitre administration
est-ce que c'est pas aussi pour contrer
un peu le le la caricature ou la
première image qui était donnée
c'est-à-dire le le plan col roulé quoi
voyez ce que je veux dire Bruno Le Maire
puis Emmanuel Macron en col roulé quoi
là là on fait c'est autre chose comme
exemple la première ministre en doudoune
aussi bon bien sûr ça ça a été une façon
un peu dérisoire on va dire de surtout
quand on sait qu'après une grande maison
de cachemire envoyer un pull en
cachemire à Bruno Le Maire donc c'est
une je l'avais pas vu passer
autrement plus sérieux pour le pour
l'exemple donné par l'état non pour
aller tout à fait dans votre sens madame
c'est montrer qu'il y a une qui doit y
avoir une justice et que tout le monde
doit y aller parce que c'est vrai que il
y a des tas de gens qui sont déjà très
sobre parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens
de ne pas l'être sobre donc
c'est trop cher mais ce qui est
important c'est de c'est de montrer que
cette fois-ci c'est que tout le monde
doit faire doit faire l'effort alors il
est évident que les efforts seront plus
faciles à supporter par les uns que par
les autres c'est évident mais l'idée que
tous les acteurs sont dedans que toute
l'administration que les entreprises
qu'on ait fait signer cette charte des
entreprises par exemple ce sont des
signes qui sont pas que symboliques qui
sont plus forts que ça pour pouvoir dire
maintenant aux entrepreneurs quand vous
ferez vraiment un plan d'économie et
bien on le signalera sur les applis on
saura que vous vous faites vraiment les
économies je pense que il y a je crois
je l'espère peut-être un changement si
vous voulez de la façon dont on
appréhende cette situation là alors
c'est vrai que le contexte géopolitique
de celui de la guerre dans l'Ukraine
mais toutes s'explique pas par la guerre
non Ukraine loin de là il faut dire ça
elle abandon quoi la guerre en Ukraine
moi je savais pas qu'il y avait tant de
choses qui venait du grain pour
expliquer l'augmentation des prix enfin
bon bref on est quand même dans une
situation un peu un peu étonnante mais
là il y a vraiment une pour ma part une
prise de conscience et le fait que
l'État 10 d'entrée de jeu nous nous
devons faire les grands efforts alors là
où ça a posé des problèmes c'est quand
il parle de l'école par exemple ou des
collèges en disant bon ben il faudra pas
chauffer alors là tous les parents
chauffer pendant le week-end mais oui
mais ce qui semble on sait aussi que
quand on ferme quand on ferme une école
pendant le week-end quand on arrive le
lundi matin il fait vraiment vraiment
frais la température remonte pas en 2
minutes quoi exactement et donc à ce
moment-là il faut faire tourner la
machine très fort pour pouvoir rattraper
les degrés
80% chez les cadres et plus l'assumer et
c'est aussi des économies sur les
déplacements financières donc et des
économies de temps pour des publics pour
qu'ils le temps est très précieux donc
c'est pas forcément le public et le plus
touché par les questions de
d'augmentation des prix par contre c'est
sûr que ça vient ça vient s'ajouter
notamment pour les foyers avec des
enfants etc mais tout dépend après
comment ça va s'organiser c'est-à-dire
que pour que ce soit efficace comme
comme le disait Erwan il faut que les
jours soient soient bien choisis
c'est-à-dire si chacun prend des jours
par-ci par là en fait il y a pas
d'économie c'est juste un report du lieu
de l'entreprise sur le chauffage du
ménage soit complètement vide on peut
pas qui est trois personnes qui
travaillent dans une tour dans un dans
un bâtiment où il fera passionnant parce
qu'on est on est très concret c'est vrai
aussi pour l'histoire des des sanitaires
pas d'eau chaude dans les sanitaires
c'est ça doit pas être si facile à
mettre en oeuvre très concret la plupart
des des sanitaires en tout cas des
bâtiments administratifs ont aujourd'hui
le circuit il est pas mélangé enfin il
est passé
donc il y a tout un tas de bâtiment
administratif
l'arrivée d'eau pour cet hiver ça
demanderait des travaux absolument donc
là c'est irréaliste et on le sait donc
c'est sûr que dès qu'on s'attaque au
détail on se rend compte qu'il y a pas
mal de propositions qui ne tiennent pas
forcément la route pour parler des 110
km/h pour les fonctionnaires personne ne
va ne va de va surveiller qui va rouler
à 110 km/h
ça dépend si ils utilisent toujours les
mêmes voitures quelle consommation
d'essence ils ont
encourage avec les syndicats sur le
l'accusation etc etc et je veux dire on
peut pas dire que c'est pas du tout
possible si
autre chose qui est intéressant
à propos du 1er novembre justement parce
que là on a un pont il y a 4 jours il y
a le lundi le samedi le dimanche donc ça
fait au moins trois jours voire
peut-être trois jours et demi vendredi
après-midi et là on va voir les
économies qui sont faites dans
l'administration sur quatre on propose
aussi de le faire sur les bureaux de
façon à avoir au moins un test pour
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on gagne à partir de
quoi on à partir de quoi ça vaut la
peine ou pas allez on va parler
communication maintenant avec vous
Laetitia et donc cette grande campagne
lancée lundi prochain et ben oui puisque
les ménages fassent déjà des efforts il
va y avoir grande campagne de
communication Emmanuel Macron la réclame
depuis cet été il a même mis 15 millions
d'euros sur la table et bien revoilà
Thomas les clips sur les réseaux les
spots télé radio les affiches comme à
l'époque du covid on va en repasser une
petite quand même j'ai pris vraiment au
hasard c'était une campagne télé de 2021
regardez
[Musique]
en restant chacun mobilisé nous serons
plus forts ensemble
[Musique]
et oui parce qu'il faut des images et un
slogan alors cette fois-ci le slogan ce
sera chaque geste compte et le Parisien
votre journal a donc dévoilé ce matin
une affiche un visuel que l'on pourra
voir dès la semaine prochaine on voit
voilà cette petite infographie avec à la
maison je règle mon chauffage sur 19
degrés maximum avec cette main qui
tourne le thermostat du radiateur et ça
marche écoutez l'exécutif oui parce que
depuis l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'Elysée et de son ex conseiller surtout
Ismaël émelien ils sont passionnés par
l'épopée Obama et ne jure que par le
nudge c'est quoi le nudge on en a
beaucoup parlé déjà pendant le covid
c'est une technique qui vient des
sciences comportementales on peut
traduire comme un coup de je sais pas un
coup de pouce on peut pas dire ça comme
ça en français ça a été mis au point par
deux Américains qui ont écrit notch en
2008 en gros c'est comment inciter en
douceur les Français à changer leur
comportement sans trop les brusquer et
puis ça s'appuie sur des billets
cognitifs et puis sur notre cerveau
émotionnel cette méthode elle a déjà été
beaucoup utilisée par la macronie mais
pas que il y a aussi les militants
justement qui luttent contre le
réchauffement climatique qui l'utilise
beaucoup exemples très concret puisqu'on
est très concret ce soir dans le 13e
arrondissement en 2023 il y aura un
bâtiment fait de bois et d'acier nudge
avec des dispositifs un peu spéciaux
exemple encore plus concret un pommeau
de douche qui changera de couleur quand
votre consommation le seuil de
consommation sera dépassé si vous prenez
une douche trop longue le gouvernement
va donc s'appuyer sur le nudge pour
cette campagne de communication ne
change jamais des méthodes qui gagnent
Thomas et donc on aura le droit un
catalogue de gestes de vie quotidienne
des slogans simples des images simples
le service d'information du gouvernement
a fait une enquête a fait une étude de
marché et ils se sont rendus compte que
la majorité des Français en tout cas
plus de 50 % disent qu'ils ne sont pas
assez informés au mal informés sur les
techniques comment faire pour pour
économiser l'énergie donc pour le moment
il y a un spot télé et cinq petits films
courts complémentaires ça je voulais
piquer dans le journal dans Le Parisien
qui sont qui vont être diffusés donc à
partir de lundi mais rien ne dit qu'il
n'y aura pas de deuxième vague de
pénurie énergétique ça c'est un peu
d'ironie mais quand même le covid est
encore très présent on parle peut-être
du 8e vague du covid donc pourquoi pas
après l'hiver une deuxième vague de
pénurie énergétique on verra ça on verra
bien je voudrais faire un petit focus
sur le nudge ça ça marche Sandra ou à
bien j'imagine que vous l'avez étudié ça
alors c'est un outil parmi d'autres en
fait pour faire changer les
comportements ça peut avoir une
efficacité par exemple sur le plan
alimentaire dans les cantines on va
mettre les fruits et légumes d'abord
pour que les enfants mettent sur leur
plateau un peu plus de fruits et légumes
et un petit peu moins d'autres d'autres
produits par exemple sur remplir ces
impôts on va vous demander au début
est-ce que vraiment vous êtes bien
sincères et on se rend compte que juste
avec cette petite phrase cette petite
question au démarrage et bien en fait on
a moins de fraudes donc voilà donc ça
peut être des astuces après il y a des
critiques qui sont faites aussi sur ces
techniques en disant que c'est un peu
paternaliste c'est à dire qu'on en fait
on décide pour les gens ce qui est bien
pour eux voilà mais c'est une technique
parmi d'autres parmi la fiscalité la
réglementation l'information la
communication la pédagogie il y a plein
d'outils pour faire changer les gens et
c'est une des facettes un des moyens de
faire changer les comportements il y a
un moyen pour qui est assez efficace et
de regarder où votre banque investit
votre argent par exemple ça ça peut être
un bon moyen pour pour avoir un impact
écologique et énergétique évidemment pas
la première campagne d'économie
d'énergie ma génération elle se souvient
de 1974 on est après le premier choc
pétrolier et alors ça je m'en souvenais
pas forcément je me souvenais du slogan
mais c'est un pêcheur à la ligne qui se
charge de transmettre le message
regardez une chose nous manque une chose
essentielle le pétrole le pétrole nous
sommes obligés de l'acheter à d'autres
chair trop cher c'est notre richesse qui
s'en va et notre façon de vivre qui est
menacée alors que peut-on faire et bien
d'abord mieux utiliser l'énergie et ça
justement nous pouvons le faire sans
changer notre façon de vivre à partir du
15 septembre l'agence pour les économies
d'énergie vous dira comment vous verrez
en France on a pas de pétrole
mais on a des idées on n'a pas de
pétrole mais on a des idées béatrisibles
à l'époque et c'est intéressant parce
que c'est dit dans le dans le spot on
veut faire des économies mais ne rien
changer à notre mode de vie la
principale différence elle est peut-être
là c'est à dire que si vous l'avez un
peu évoqué mais cette idée qu'on doit on
est en train peut-être d'inventer un
autre modèle économique 73 personnes
n'imaginaient réchauffement climatique
sauf quelques grands physiciens et
quelques grands climatologues mais je
veux dire globalement là majorité de la
population n'était pas et de
sensibiliser véritablement assez à ces
problèmes là donc c'était cette idée que
on allait pas changer véritablement de
mode de vie qu'on allait s'adapter à un
prix du pétrole qui avait
considérablement augmenté pour des
situations géopolitiques comme on l'a
d'une certaine façon ici avec
l'augmentation du prix du gaz russe
c'est une situation géopolitique qui a
des conséquences extrêmement rapides si
vous voulez dans des augmentations de
prix très très fort et et quelle
surprise effectivement tout le monde
mais on est parti derrière avec le plan
du nucléaire qui a été effectivement
dans les années 70 un moment de très
fort développement du nucléaire là où on
est en situation de difficulté c'est
encore à mon sens pour une analyse de
situation politique ou le nucléaire on
l'a beaucoup freiné parce que en 97
quand Lionel Jospin devient premier
ministre il a impérativement besoin
d'appui des vers et cet appui là il va
devoir le payer et il le paye entre
autre chose en arrêtant toute la
recherche sur Phoenix qui était le
une la possibilité de réfléchir à la
réutilisation des déchets du nucléaire
pour les remettre en circulation et où
le nucléaire devient affreux et il faut
arrêter le nucléaire c'est dangereux bon
et seulement il est bien évident que
c'est pas avec du solaire et avec du
vent qu'on va effectivement régler
compenser l'arrêt du nucléaire mais on a
eu avec ce discours très hostile au
nucléaire je pense qu'il y a des tas de
gens qui d'ingénieurs qui ne sont pas
allés vers le nucléaire parce que bon
c'était pas très motivant c'était pas
une très valorisant puis on disait qu'on
allait plus en faire et puis l'affaire
de tchernobylo petit à petit on a perdu
on a perdu notre savoir-faire et notre
leadership et notre leadership et puis
ça se rattrape pas quand même pas comme
ça alors il y a quelqu'un qui connaît
très bien le dossier qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire ce qu'elle
vient de dire béatrigible est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est un grille de
lecture finalement un peu idéologique
venu notamment des verres Allemands des
grunonnes qui s'est un petit à petit
imposé dans le débat politique français
non c'est quand même oublié qu'il y a eu
trois grandes catastrophes nucléaires
celle de 86 Tchernobyl
avant d'ailleurs 79 Island aux
États-Unis et puis en 2011 évidemment
fushima fushima ça a quand même
énormément marqué l'esprit de de dans le
monde entier et aujourd'hui
effectivement on relance le nucléaire à
coup de dizaines voire de centaines de
milliards de d'euros les 6 EPR qu'on
voudrait construire
d'ici à 2040 si on est très optimiste
vont nous coûter au bas mot plus de 60
milliards d'euros il suffirait d'un
incident un peu sérieux et j'espère pas
un accident pour que à nouveau ça
rebatte complètement les cartes donc il
faut être assez prudent je dis
absolument pas là je me prononce ni pour
ni contre le nucléaire je pense que
c'est une technologie extrêmement
complexe et donc il faut l'aborder avec
toutes les toutes les précautions
possibles je vous interrompre parce que
c'est un peu échappé je reviens mais
c'était passionnant je reviens donc
assez à ce plan sobriété annoncé par le
gouvernement on va se concentrer sur les
entreprises maintenant et je propose à
tam-train de de nous rejoindre elles
sont également mis à contribution Tam
euh
bonsoir bonsoir les les producteurs
d'énergie Bruno Le Maire a annoncé alors
c'était pas aujourd'hui c'était hier
cherché la rente des fournisseurs
d'énergie et de quelle rampe on parle et
bien on parle de la rente qui a été
générée par la flambée des prix de
l'électricité les énergéticiens comme
EDF comme engie comme Total énergie et
bien aussi tous les fournisseurs
alternatifs qui existent sur le marché
bien tout cela ils se sont enrichis
particulièrement ces derniers temps car
les prix sont passés en un an de moins
de 100 euros le mégawattheure à 1000
euros aujourd'hui alors pas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui mais c'est allé jusqu'à 1000
euros une multiplication par 10 des prix
ils ont donc fait des bénéfices que l'on
peut qualifier d'exceptionnel en vendant
l'énergie à un prix très supérieur à son
cou de production aux entreprises
notamment au PME et puis aussi aux
collectivités qui n'ont pas droit au
bouclier tarifaire alors par exemple
engie ou totale énergie on doublait leur
profit grâce à cette inflation engie a
fait 5 milliards d'euros de bénéfices
net au deuxième trimestre 2022 total
énergie 5,6 x 2 par rapport à l'année
que propose le ministre de l'Économie
donc hier il y a donc une réunion avec
les fournisseurs d'énergie et Bruno Le
Maire n'a pas mâché ses mots il veut
s'emparer de ses bénéfices exceptionnels
écoutés on se met pas taxer tout le
monde comme certains le proposent
on dit juste que les énergéticiens ne
peuvent pas profiter de manière indue
d'une orange liée à des prix délirants
500 600 euros 1000 euros sur les marchés
spot c'est pas possible voilà notez que
Bruno Le Maire applique finalement ce
qui a été acté la semaine dernière au
niveau européen les ministres de
l'énergie des 27 ont décidé d'un prix
plafonné qui est fixé à 180 euros le
mégawattheure du premier décembre
prochain au 30 juin 2023 tout chiffre
engrangé au-delà et bien va être
récupérée par les États membres c'est
donc parce que va faire la France qui
entend ainsi récupérer 5 à 7 milliards
d'euros pour les redistribuer au PME aux
collectivités qui leur réclament à corps
et acry entre parenthèses c'est ce qu'on
a vu hier aux questions au gouvernement
au Sénat trois questions sur ce sujet
pour ces collectivités qui sont
étranglées par la montée des prix
d'énergie finalement Bruno Le Maire
récupère les super profits
sur les super profits non attention
a dû s'aligner sur les positions de nos
partenaires européens qui commençaient à
taxer les fameux super profils merci à
bientôt tout à l'heure dans notre second
débat Béatrice Giblin est-ce que c'est
quand même un peu différent
effectivement d'une tag sur les super
profils différents parce que là ça
concerne le chiffre d'affaires c'est pas
seulement les bénéfices c'est à dire
tout ce qui sera au-dessus de 180 euros
du mégawattheure donc c'est l'ensemble
du chiffre d'affaires de l'entreprise
donc elle est limite on peut récupérer
plus d'argent que si on avait taxé que
les bénéfices donc c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose alors le fait que c'est au
fond quelque chose qui c'est quand même
un peu mis en place plutôt Portugal
l'Espagne voilà donc c'est c'est au
niveau européen je pense que ça va
s'appliquer à tout le monde
l'Europe elle avance toujours dans les
crises donc rien n'était possible le
coût des 200 milliards que l'Allemagne a
annoncé pour valider ces entreprises
voilà ça a quand même un peu bousculé
tout le monde et on s'est dit il faut
qu'on se calme là il faut qu'on ait une
position commune et ce qui va être
important derrière je crois c'est
l'importance du plafonnement du prix du
gaz
qu'on n'arrive pas encore à voir les les
Allemands sont très hostiles pourquoi
ils sont aussi parce qu'ils se disent
mais si on plafonne le prix du gaz alors
on va plus nous le vendre ni les
Algériens ni les Norvégiens ni bon et
nous on en a impérativement besoin qu'il
ferait que les Algériens etc exactement
c'est ça qui doit se négocier et on y
vient je pense que on y vient on y
viendra mais ce serait très important
parce que et pas que le gaz russe si on
plafonne parce que plafonné le gastrux
on va y arriver relativement assez vite
plafonner tout le gaz qu'on achète ça ça
va être beaucoup beaucoup plus difficile
mais c'est effectivement le prix de
l'électricité étant calculé dans ce
système un peu particulier sur le prix
du gaz si on fait bais du gaz on fait
baisser le prix d'électricité on fait
baisser l'inflation alors il y a deux
éléments il y a cette mesure la les 180
mégawattheure je vous pose la question
d'un instant mais il y a l'impact dans
l'opinion je voudrais bien vous entendre
la vue c'est quoi ça rejoint ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est attention à
ce que on ne se dise pas qu'il y a des
profiteurs de cette crise ça c'est un
sentiment assez profond qui s'exprimer
quoi et qui s'exprime régulièrement oui
et qui est présent dans la société
française depuis très longtemps j'ai la
société française est très sensible aux
inégalités beaucoup plus que d'autres
pays européens même si globalement on va
dire qu'on a quand même un pays avec peu
d'inégalités alors elles sont toujours
trop importantes mais voilà donc il y a
vraiment ce regard cette exigence on va
dire et puis notamment donc à
l'intérieur des ménages entre les riches
et les pauvres mais également entre les
entreprises et les ménages et au sein
des entreprises les ménages font depuis
très longtemps la différence entre les
petites entreprises et la figure de la
multinationale qui elle est perçue
davantage comme pouvant
focaliser ayant des moyens aussi
finalement de tirer son épingle du jeu
donc le fait de d'agir sur des grandes
entreprises ça va dans le sens des
attentes du public après c'est vrai que
c'est un type de marché la même chose
n'a pas été fait par exemple sur les
médicaments alors qu'il y a quand même
la sécurité sociale finance une grande
partie des médicaments etc etc on sait
qu'il y a eu des profits pendant la
période covid donc bon mais c'est en
tout cas c'est une grande société de
transport maritime aussi qui font des
profits un peu exceptionnels en tout cas
c'est ça va dans ce sens là mais c'est
pas c'est pas complexe sur la mesure
elle-même donc ce trip plafonné 180
euros le mégawattheure du premier
décembre cette année jusqu'au 30 juin
prochain il y a un truc pardon mais que
je ne comprends pas
quel intérêt pour les entreprises de
continuer à le vendre plus cher
ce qui va se passer elles vont pas le
vendre à 250 ou à 300 euros puisque de
toute façon ça leur rapportera rien
c'est pour ça que moi je
j'ai beaucoup de mal à y croire à ce à
ce système je ne je ne vois pas et j'en
ai discuté avec des experts des traders
des choses comme ça je ne vois pas
comment ça peut au bout du compte être
appliqué donc je serai difficilement
répondre à votre question parce que je
ne comprends pas le système ensuite il y
a aussi un autre point taxé enfin taxer
les entreprises sur les super profits je
trouve qu'il y a un peu quand même une
confusion des genres entre des
entreprises qui produisent de l'énergie
il y a des prix de marché qui sont fixés
parce que et de façon plutôt libre donc
après on peut les on peut les encadrer
pourquoi pas mais elle ne profite pas
c'est-à-dire que elle profiterait si
elles ont si elles ont manipulé les
marchés pour pouvoir faire augmenter les
prix et effectivement il est sur la
redistribution bah elle profite
vous avez une maison que vous voulez
revendre vous avez vu une voiture vous
voulez revendre puis votre voiture elle
a pris de la valeur parce que par
exemple aller plus rechercher qu'avant
donc vous avez
je sais pas là par contre dans un
contexte de sobriété et tout le monde
c'est intéressant parce que
effectivement ça rejoint la vision qu'on
peut avoir de de l'entreprise du patron
en France c'est pas totalement mais
c'est il y a quand même question de
répartition de ces bénéfices
exceptionnels ou pas sont-ils liés à la
stratégie de ces groupes ou pas bon on
peut en débattre c'est en ce moment s'il
y a une grève chez Total énergie dans
les raffineries c'est pour ça parce que
je dis pas que les syndicats ont raison
ils disent ils disent ils disent ils
font la meilleure répartition de la
riche ah ça c'est autre chose enfin
c'est autre chose on est quand même au
cœur du dossier oui non tout à fait mais
on est dans un contexte où effectivement
la donne sur le marché du travail là
c'est presque au sujet il faudra que
votre émission est en train de changer
on parle de grand de grande démission
aux études on parle quicking etc et
aujourd'hui la la effectivement le
rapport de force est modifié et là on
voit un peu partout notamment en France
mais pas que des salariés qui disent bah
nous aussi on veut en profiter donc là
bon c'est tout le débat sur répartition
il y a une confusion sur les les
fournisseurs là quand Bruno Le Maire
parle des profiteurs il parle aussi de
des fournisseurs d'électricité et des
gens qui ne sont pas forcément des
producteurs et qui ont bénéficié d'une
électricité achetée à bas prix notamment
l'électricité nucléaire vendu par EDF et
qui la revendent au lieu d'en faire
bénéficier hors clients le revendre sur
les marchés là ce sont effectivement des
profiteurs et là il y a déjà un
fournisseur qui aujourd'hui fait l'objet
d'une enquête et d'autres fournisseurs
qui sont sous le coup le le coût des
projecteurs de la DGCCRF et de la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
c'est un voilà je trouve qu'il faut
remettre le dans le débat les les
différentes les grandes entreprises et
qu'est-ce que c'est de profiter de la
situation je trouve que des bail est
passionnant parce qu'on voit que
derrière un plan comme celui-là il y a
la complexité finalement de
l'application de la mise en oeuvre de de
ces mesures c'est bon on verra et sous
le pied sur l'application de la mise en
oeuvre et mesure notamment sur le
chauffage mais je sais pas si on a le
temps il nous reste 6 minutes vous avez
vu l'affiche tout à l'heure qui était
parue ce matin dans le Parisien on voit
un compteur vous avez vu sur thermostat
sur le radiateur qu'est-ce qui a marqué
sur le sur le radiateur sur les
thermostat 1 2 3 4 5 6 à quoi ça
correspond à la puissance de votre
radiateur c'est tout par contre ce qui
est demandé par le gouvernement l'une
des mesures c'est de dire à 19 degrés et
donc maintenant je vais vous poser la
question ici sur cette table qui chez
lui un thermomètre qui lui indique la
température de son logement qui alors
vous bravo moi je l'ai passé à
l'extérieur c'est en France
c'est pas compliqué mais aujourd'hui qui
a un thermomètre qui a qui qui a un
appareil qui permet d'enregistrer le
taux d'humidité il faut que ce soit en
dessous de 70% ce que je veux dire par
là c'est qu'en fait il y a plein de
personnes notamment les copropriété 5
millions de personnes qui ne savent pas
à quelle température il fait chez eux
donc ça va être là aussi c'est un détail
mais dans le concret la mise en
application risque d'être très compliqué
alors puisqu'on est là aussi pour pour
faire de la pédagogie et que vous vous
l'avez dit il y a beaucoup de Français
qui qui savent pas quel geste privilégié
etc je vous propose d'écouter un autre
extrait de la conférence de presse tout
à l'heure c'est Agnès panorinache qui
justement liste un peu les les gestes de
sobriété que de nous Français citoyen
nous allons pouvoir faire ces trois
idées simples je baisse j'éteins je
décale elles sont illustrées par les 5
gestes les plus efficaces selon les
experts pour réduire sa consommation
régler son chauffage à 19 degrés maximum
régler son chauffe-eau à 55 degrés et
rester moins longtemps sous la douche
éteindre tous ces appareils en marche ou
en veille lorsqu'ils ne sont pas
utilisés ça c'est vraiment le geste qui
ne vous coûte rien et qui rapporte
beaucoup
décaler l'utilisation de ces appareils
électroniques comme les lave-vaisselles
les sèche-linge je vais pas rentrer dans
tout l'inventaire de la cuisine en
dehors des périodes de pointe 8 heures à
13h et 18h à 20h et le dernier geste
s'est installé un thermostat
programmable
alors c'est une oeuvre collective en
fait qu'on nous demande de créer d'une
certaine façon je lisais ce matin
éditorial du directeur de rédaction de
du Parisien Aujourd'hui en France
Nicolas Charbonneau il fait le pari que
les Français vont faire preuve de
civisme comme pendant la crise covid
Sandra bien moi ce qui ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est qu'effectivement les
aînés les événements qui nous permettent
de faire société ils sont assez rares
est-ce que ça peut en être d'après vous
ce défi là de baisser collectivement
notre consommation de d'énergie oui
alors ça c'est des choses qui sont très
connues ancien social c'est que dans les
moments de crise effectivement il y a
plus de cohésion et on l'a vu pendant la
crise covid on a quand même beaucoup
décrits des Français pendant très
longtemps comme des gens indiscipliner
tout le monde est resté chez soi a suivi
les recommandations même au-delà des
recommandations etc donc ça sur le
moment oui la question c'est après la
crise c'est à dire est-ce que s'il est
pris de de l'énergie se mettent à
redimir ce qui est possible parce qu'on
fait souvent des émissions au moment des
pics des prix mais beaucoup moins quand
les prix diminuent est-ce que les
ménages vont se remettre à consommer
comme avant et donc c'est pour ça que
les les tous les changements qui sont
demandés sont des changements ce que je
vous ai tout à l'heure c'est à dire des
changements de petits geste et pas des
changements vraiment profonds de mode de
vie donc oui à court terme à long terme
il faudrait qu'il y ait un
accompagnement un peu plus global c'est
quoi c'est le prix peut-être qui va être
le levier du long terme
ce qui est le plus dissuasif plus vous
baissez le prix de l'essence plus vous
prenez votre voiture plus quand vous
pouvez le faire évidemment on est dans
des endroits où c'est difficile
évidemment on va continuer à prendre sa
voiture mais il est évident que le prix
est dissuasif je veux dire les
compagnies low cost d'avion ont permis
d'aller passer un week-end à Barcelone à
Rome etc est-ce que c'était pas cher si
c'est cher vous le faites pas parce que
votre niveau de vie ne vous permet pas
de le faire donc le est un élément
incontestable du changement de
comportement alors c'est là que
l'équation est compliquée parce que
aujourd'hui on peut pas on peut pas
laisser filer les prix parce qu'il y a
une partie de la société française qui
le supporte pas exactement et le
problème c'est jusqu'où on peut aller
dans l'élasticité de ceux qui vont
supporter ou pas supporter et comment on
peut cibler ceux qui sont les plus
fragiles sans faire une usine à gaz sans
que ça coûte tellement cher pour
contrôler et qu'on est que ceux qui en
aient besoin
bien évidemment il y a toute une série
d'aide qui sont qui sont passées comme
ça donc je pense effectivement que c'est
sur du long terme qu'on pourra faire des
vrais économies donc les logements bien
évidemment ou le transport aérien en
faisant des efforts moins de
consommation de kérosène ou autre ça
veut dire des vrais changements
incontestablement mais déjà prendre
l'habitude au terme au moment de crise
de changer de comportement
si on a de nouveau par exemple un été
très très chaud comme on en est cette
année je veux dire les gens comprennent
que ah ben c'est pas seulement la crise
liée à la guerre en Ukraine c'est qu'on
est vraiment dans quelque chose qui est
en train de changer et la question de
l'eau que vous souleviez qui est à mon
avis très intéressant c'est celle qui
permet le plus de faire prendre
conscience de la complexité et des
conséquences d'une chaîne voilà en effet
domino et si jamais il y avait une
deuxième un deuxième métier aussi chaud
je pense que vraiment les gens se sont
prêts à tout dernier mot allez-y à Juan
Benezet malheureusement iris il risque
d'en avoir mais ce signal prix il est
pris en compte par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui les mesures qui ont été
présentées la cinquantaine de mesures le
Gouvernement estime que ça ça va
permettre de faire baisser de 3% la
consommation sur les 10% qui sont prévus
vous savez je crois 50 terawatts
les 7% ça sera le prix justement ils
estiment que ce sont les l'effet prix
sur la consommation qui permettra
d'atteindre les 10% 3%, 7% avec le prix
c'est là où on se rend compte que les
mesures ont certains poids mais c'est
peut-être pas celui qui pèsera le plus
pour arriver aux objectifs merci
beaucoup merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat et à bientôt sur ce
plateau pour sens public